Good morning.
We were discussing about the
model evaluation, so we were
middle in the middle of the
discussion and then we ran out
of the time.
So we will continue the
discussion.
I hope. OK.
So you can all of you have been
unmuted so you feel free to
interrupt if something is not
clear.
The so these are all the review
points.
So we had seen that we it's not
easy to think about the he
accuracy metric without a proper
method to estimate the accuracy.
Uh.
The point is that when we build
the model, we build the model
using the training data, but
then we will consider the
classifier as effective only if
it can work well with unseen
data, that is, tuples, which it
has never seen.
So there are methods.
So we had seen the definitions
for when it is a two class
confusion matrix.
He has seen that there can be
true positive false negatives,
false positives, true negatives.
So this is representing the
actuals, the actual class, and
then this is the predicted
class.
And so we have seen the example
of how to compute the these are
the desirable things, and these
are the undesirable things.
So so when you are trying to
evaluate the the estimate the
accuracy, so you are going to
consider these.
So you are effectively making it
6954 plus.
Couldn't find 88.
These are these are the things
for which things have gone right
out of the 10,000 cases, and we
have seen that the the accuracy
and error rate, while we can
decide from the.
Are the cross tabulation of the
classifier results?
Uh, this is all also referred as
a confusion matrix.
And when we have unbalanced
classes, so we can may require
additional measures like
sensitivity and specificity.
And we can have for example some
test cases where we will get 2
positives which are desirable.
Suppose this is the important
class.
Uh, so.
So let it be something like for
example, we have done a search
for something on one of these
search engines, so the search
engine returned, let's say 200
pages.
And out of them, out of those
pages really.
So really 100, and let's say 100
are relevant.
And we somehow know that there
are actually in the web there
are 150 relevant pages.
And the setting in return only
100.
So now what we can say is that
so the out of these 150 only 100
have gone into the true
positives and other fifty became
false positives.
Positives.
Sorry, so sorry, false
negatives.
And among these 200 pages that
are returned by the search
engine, 100 are relevant and 100
or false positives.
OK, so they are not relevant,
but they are.
So, so we what we do is we
compute when 200 pages are
returned and out of 100 are
relevant.
Then we call that as a precision
measure, 100 by 200, and when
there are 150 relevant pages and
only hundred of them have been
returned, we say that is about
the recall saying that 100 out
of the 150 actual positive pages
have been returned.
Pages have been returned so we
can combine these two precision
and recall.
You get a school which is you
have school, which is a harmonic
mean.
So we had this is this part we
had discussed in the last class.
Is it?
Is it a problem with the hearing
me?
Well, Sir.
Also OK, because I see some
someone.
OK, Miss Manisha, Ravi saying
that she's not able to hear
anyone.
OK, I think you need to check
these speaker on your system.
Maybe she can't hear even this
message from me.
OK, so now my question.
OK, so now let us look at a
graph.
And here what we are saying is
that the recall is fixed at 70%.
So there is a classifier for
which recall is 70% and the
precision it changed based on
various ways.
The precision changes from 100
zero to 100 and then we compute
a metric which is representing a
combination of precision and
recall as the precision changes
from zero to 100.
So we have there are three
metrics that are used.
One is 1 is representing the.
Arithmetic mean right?
Athematic mean and another one
is representing.
Geometric mean and the another
one is representing harmonic
mean.
So when you look at these three,
what is it that you gather?
Is the question clear?
Can you do better?
Cannot do it too.
Uh, yes, somebody speaking.
Can you repeat the question,
Sir?
Can you repeat the question?
Yes, yes, I'm going to repeat,
OK, I'm I'm not able to see who
Yes, of course.
is speaking because I I don't
know, because the interface got
changed.
It is not.
Or in them, Sir.
Find themselves.
Yes, music, burning them,
burning them.
Or in them.
OK.
Because generally what happens
is that the moment a person
speaks, that icon comes to the
front.
So, OK, fine, now I'm because
this is a little latest release
of teams from Microsoft.
Maybe, maybe some things that we
need to catch up with it.
OK, so fine Mr adding them.
So let me repeat the question.
So what we are saying is that we
want to create a metric which
combines the precision and
recall.
So let's say there are three
options.
One is that you can combine them
as an arithmetic mean, and you
can combine them as a geometric
mean, and you can combine them
as harmonic mean.
A is arithmetic mean Gee is
geometric mean and which is
harmonic mean.
So what is your observation?
From this graph, we are plotting
all three.
Mr Arindam is this clear now the
question is clear is yeah, OK,
Yes, Sir.
because the precision and recall
can be combined and then they
can take various values.
But for the simplicity for
plotting the graph, we fix it.
The recall and kept on varying
the precision, and then we
plotted this as a graph saying
that what will be the harmonic
mean as the precision changes
from zero to 100.
Similarly, what is the
arithmetic mean as it precision
changes from zero to 100, So
what do you observe when you
look at these three?
I'm hoping that you will get the
answer instead of my giving it.
They eventy percent.
OK, OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, please go ahead.
What is the question?
And it is not question, it's
heaven Divya sent.
And it is not question.
He was in the 70% recall is
fixed because otherwise the
graph will become a lot more
complex.
We need a 3D graph, so for that
what we did is that we fixed the
recall at 70% and changing only
precision versus a metric.
The metric can be anything.
Arithmetic mean, harmonic mean,
geometric mean, or even min or
Max.
OK.
Mr SOUMYA has observed that it
is intersecting it 70 OK that is
fine.
But when both of them are 70,
all the metrics are becoming 70
OK.
So what else are you observing?
When both recall and precision,
or 70, then we are getting all
Arithmetic mean is.
the metrics at 70.
Yeah, fine, no problem.
OK, arithmetic mean does not
start from zero, Mr Subroto Roy
has observed.
OK, that is a good point.
Yeah.
What mode did you observe?
Yes, that is that is 1
observation, right? Good.
OK, Miss GURSIMRAN has a has an
interesting observation.
A is greater than G, is greater
than H So what does that mean?
You can speak.
I I I I hope the mic of
everybody is enabled.
He said it's enabled.
Yes, that's her name for it.
I just have an observation.
I don't know the meaning.
Yes, yes, that is good.
That is good.
A is greater than G is greater
than a.
That is, that is in fact the
answer.
One of the answers I'm looking
for what else?
I mean, what is the conclusion
you draw from that?
Because from harmonic mean only,
we get the defunct for.
Maybe you have to be louder.
Someone Mr Ranganathan is
speaking, but it is the voice is
Harmonic.
coming low.
You come closer to the your
microphone and speak.
Not only, yeah, actually
harmonic mean will give this
Yeah, harmonic to me.
score between the recession and
we'll call.
But it give the temples were
Vicky direction and make
project.
So that's why the harmonic made
is best parameter.
So that's why they had my.
OK, I think you are trying to
say is the harmonic mean is the
most conservative estimate,
which combines precision and
recall, is that correct?
Yes.
It is the most conservative uh
metric when you have been given
the precision and recall, and
that is the reason possible
reason why F score is built
using harmonic mean, not
arithmetic mean or geometric
mean.
So so the so this way what we
are doing is we are taking the
so essentially what we are
saying is if score is equal to.
OK, so so that that will give
you the same, right?
Yeah, right.
So this is the harmonic mean.
OK, so it is understood.
Then you people got the answer.
So why we choose a metric of F
score rather than arithmetic
mean to decide which is a better
classifier?
OK.
I just a quick.
Yes, Mr Rajesh, go ahead.
OK so.
OK, so 539 and I still have
tightly brown, but it's what
Find that you know that these
two are tightly bone, but admin
geometric.
does it signify this?
And what does it signify?
Why?
Why is it at?
Why?
Why is that?
Why is it?
Uh, what is harmonic mean title
method beyond the mathematical
What is Harman method beyond the
mathematical patterns?
part of?
Ah, let's see.
There is nothing.
It's nothing is stopping us from
taking a geometric mean.
So you got precision and recall.
You say that you will use the
geometric mean of the two to
qualify a classifier, because
finally we want to we can build
many classifiers, so by now you
have already seen that we can
build 2 classifiers and then if
you studied in the any of the
textbooks it says that OK it is
easily there are 10 methods to
build classifiers.
So now the question is that each
of them will give different
precision and recall and then
and you need to compare which
one is better.
So to compare, it is better to
have single school.
Is that correct?
So then how to create that
single score?
That is, which one among these
like?
Just like of the decision that
you know Herman, you know
The decision that you know
Harmonian is better.
better.
What does it signify?
Like mathematically we see the
graph a bit higher.
Black.
Mathematically, will see the
graph a bit higher.
That is fine.
Umm.
Uh, but why is that happening?
But once that happening.
Is it because athletic for me
out there?
OK, OK, OK, Now, now, now, now
I'm seeing on most of the
authors are most of the
researchers like to compare the
F score, but then that does not
mean that you cannot use any
other metric or we In Sync.
OK, fine.
It's more of convention rather
than significant advance.
Let's what a finishing rather
than yeah, that is right,
because most of the researchers
like to compare the performance
using the F score and.
OK.
But then if you say that you
want to compare individually
precision recall that is fine.
And then if you want to take the
arithmetic mean also, but then
what we know is that the
harmonic mean is a more
conservative because sometimes
we get metrics where the
precision, recall having widely
varying values.
For example, let us look at the
web example in the Web example I
said 150 relevant page and out
of them 100 recalled 100 are
there in the test results, but
in real web you know that when
you are searching for, let us
say some something which is some
something which is a kind of an
art or something which is a real
kind of thing.
It is possible that there are
thousands of pages, but it is
not able to capture them.
So it may be able to capture
only much many fewer number.
So they recall maybe far lower,
so only 10, while the precision
may be, it may be going into
708090.
So now how do you know when you
have multiple sets?
Changes.
How will you compare them so so
The thing is that you need to
combine the two because if you
go with only one maybe maybe you
may not reach a ideal solution.
OK.
Makes sense.
OK.
Makes sense.
Thank you.
OK, let us let us go with the
further.
So it is also possible that you
want to give higher weightage to
one of them compared to the
other.
So if we say that instead of
taking half and half, you want
to take go with something else.
So what you say is that alpha is
equal to .75 and 1 minus alpha
is equal to .25.
So there by what you are we are
saying is that we are giving a
differential credits to
precision and recall.
So in that case you will end up
with a different metric, so it
is typically expressed in the
form of the beta square, which
is equal to 1 minus alpha by
alpha, and that indicates the
ratio of importance that we want
to give to the two, and we end
up with the YF beta score which
is expressed this way.
OK, now let us look at a
classifier is built, so a
classifier for.
Medical diagnostics.
So you are looking at the
results of the classifier the
classifier has been used to test
a lot of data that's available.
So there are 10,000 cases or
available with some hospital and
they have evaluated the
classifier.
So what do you think about this
classifier?
The accuracy is.
90 + 9560 is 9650 is 96.5%.
And what do you think about this
classifier on 96.4?
I don't know 96.5 that is what
it is coming to me.
So in this cancer equal to
critical to identify that even
So in this cancer, will the
difficult to identify, even
though it's only three point,
the wrongly added right a
though it's only three uh
wrongly, I didn't. Right.
rightly identified.
Uh.
Rightly identified.
Umm.
Umm, OK OK, so So what do you
what do you say about the
Well, no.
classifier?
We probably are not happy with
it because the all.
The probably are not happy with
it.
OK.
OK, Mr Rajesh is not happy.
OK.
OK fine.
Except it.
And what are the comments from
anybody else?
Anyone has anything else to say?
OK, the the data we can see it
accuracy is 96.5 for when we are
And with the data we can see it
accuracy is 96.5 for when we are
checking the cancer is no for no
it is working perfect almost
checking the cancer is no umm no
no it is working perfect.
perfect.
Almost perfect, right?
Right, right.
But then that is not important
for the domain, right?
Good.
And because we are talking about
a very serious disease.
So so we are we are concerned
about having a almost 100%
recall even if something else
goes wrong, we just won't even
if the precision is bad, we
don't mind.
But the recall has to be 100%
uh, so the sensitivity has to be
100%.
We don't care about the other
metrics, so this is a this is a
bad one, right?
OK, so now now let us look at
how can we evaluate a classifier
accuracy.
So what we know is that we can
build, we know some algorithms
to build classifier and we know
that there is a training data so
training data.
And we want to, we want to use
the training data, let us say
let us say we partition.
There are many people who have
talked about many percentages
and all that.
So suppose this is the training
data that is given to you.
So you may use this for training
and this for testing.
And then then we are going to
let's say 2062 thirds is used
for training and 1/3 is used for
testing and now what should be
the accuracy?
How how do you want to evaluate
the accuracy of this classifier?
So the point is that yes, so you
may want to use the test set for
deciding the accuracy or the
estimating the accuracy.
Do you think that is the ideal?
Using the test set to decide the
accuracy when you have a, you
have kept the remaining part for
the training.
Sir if.
More vacation that thing.
It's not good morning.
Training data set is 2 third of
the model.
Banning dataset is 2 third of
the model, yes, so then that be
Shouldn't that be used to
determine the accuracy?
useful to determine the
accuracy.
It's having a larger data.
It's having a larger data that
that is that is actually.
See, the point is that we have
every option because see, the
point is your company cannot
give you more than 1000 records
to build the classifier because
that is all that they have.
So now you are concern is that
you want to build a classifier
also to satisfy yourself that
you have done a good job.
So now what is the way in which
you can satisfy yourself that
you are accuracy is is
reasonable or that you've got a
reasonable estimate of your
accuracy because you can go with
a belief that you have built
100% accuracy and then your
customers may laugh because on
the first day it gave me gave
them a result of some 60% or
50%.
Again my friend.
So now what is the day you can.
We can give more.
Yeah, go ahead.
We can do more vacays to their
testing results, so that's
We can do that testing results,
sending it in expected to
failing.
It is expected to perform on the
training.
perform on the training.
So we can divide the training
data.
So we can divide the training,
OK, we can divide the training
data into what?
Uh.
Into multiple chunk and base for
the but.
Uh.
Into multiple chunk and based
from yes, yes I I think the idea
is coming out is good because
when you have taken let us say
fixed 700 so thousand records
you got 660 you got them as a
training set and then you build
the model and then you have
So can you?
taken another.
340 as the test set and you
evaluate it, but then it is
Sir, can we run the multiple
time that is data?
possible for the multiple times
that is data.
Yes, what you can do is that you
can also say that OK now I
rotate that.
So what I will do is that
instead of sticking with a fixed
training set and test set, I may
say that I'm going to use this
as the.
This is I'm building a model.
Let's say I have built a model.
So you M so Y M1 is built like
this, but I can also try repeat
this saying that I will build a
M2 with.
This says the test set and this
says the training set and see
how is it?
How are you going to get the
result right?
So similarly you can try
multiple times, keep building
the multiple models and then you
can get an idea of the approach
you are taking.
How good is your approach?
Because this model is not going
to be ideal identical to what
you built as a M1M2 and M1 are
not going to be identical.
But then it is possible that you
use the same algorithm, but then
the algorithm will come out with
a different set of parameters,
or so.
The point is, if you are
building rules, the rules can
turn out to be slightly
different, but the sequence of
the rules or the importance of
the rules may change, or the
because the they may get
different files, scores or some
other scores that you are using.
So the point is that but then it
says that you get an idea of
what is it that kind of accuracy
you can get from this training
data when you try multiple
times.
Sir, I have a question.
So this is uh, OK are we?
I said I have a.
Yes, that I will.
Yes, yes, go ahead.
Yeah.
So when we are partitioning the
data right one by three.
Also, when we impacting that
data right one by three?
Umm.
So basically a we consider the
fact that the population is not
So basically people considering
the fact that.
too densely populated, right?
Right.
Let's say two by three of the
the they shouldn't have the
That's two by three of the.
entire, let's say one class and
the other.
Basically, they should not be
cured subsets, right?
Hello.
What are you talking on mute?
Yeah, that is correct, yes,
because what happened is I
wanted to so previously people
said it is echoing.
So I put myself on mute.
OK, So what I'm saying is that,
uh, what I'm saying is that the
when it data is given to you, it
training data, you will believe
that the entire training data is
as valuable as the one part as
the other part.
So you have no basis for you to
really, unless you have a real
domain expertise and you think
straight away that this data was
really collected through a very
improper way.
And so that is invaluable.
Not valuable, but then otherwise
you have to depend on the entire
data.
And because finally the data is
in set you want to use the
entire value of that are we In
Sync or uh, am I talking
something different than what
you expected?
No, no.
I think we're going to you.
No, I didn't know what you.
So the point is how to make use
of the entire data, so the point
is if you start with for
example, we have looked at only
toy datasets, but we can always.
So when you've got 1000 records,
you know that if you use first
600 records, you're going to get
a different model.
Then you use the last 600
records.
So now you use the same
algorithm, but since you change
the data, you're going to get
different model.
So possible that can give you an
indication of the efficiency of
your algorithm, because you may
want to use both the models.
Or you may want to.
We will see.
You may want to build an
ensemble of both the models,
that is a different thing, but
then that gives you an idea of
what is the estimated accuracy
that you can get from the data.
So now finally, you may even go
for using the entire 1000
records to build a new model,
because once you got an idea
that OK, every time I try with
various subsets I'm getting a
75% accuracy.
Fine.
Maybe I'll come in all of that
and 75% J.
Accuracy that your customer will
be happy with.
Maybe I will use the entire data
now and build a new model, but
then R estimating the accuracy
is not a trivial task.
That is what I hope you
understood by now.
So one of the ways we can
estimate the accuracy is with
the step called cross
validation.
So cross validation, what we are
saying is that it's essentially
what we have been discussing.
So suppose that I have got go.
Let me create a 5 partitions.
So I call them as T1T2T3T4T5 and
then what I will do is that this
is the.
Now I'm taking K is equal to 5.
So what I do is that I build
Model 1 so the test data is.
Guys.
Alright.
So Model 2 test data is T2, so
on.
So you build the five models and
then thereby you're going to get
an idea of what is the
classifier accuracy through the
cross validation.
Because you have five models and
then you're looking at the
accuracy of each one and that
will give you an idea of the
overall accuracy of the model
when you build it using the
entire data.
OK, so there is another approach
that people suggest easy
bootstrapping model.
So in bootstrapping model they
work.
It works like this.
Suppose that you have a.
You have 1000 training records.
And then what we do is that we
sample with replacement.
Sample the training data from
the training records with the
replacement.
So what?
What is the probability that?
One record is not selected, is 1
by one, 1 -, 1 by 1000, right?
So when you are selecting one
record from the 1000 records,
the probability of it getting
selected is 1 by 1000,
probability of not getting
selected is 1 -, 1 by 1000.
But now what we do is that let
us say we repeat the process
1000 times, we have 1000 records
and we repeat the process for
1000 times.
Uh, so that now what we did is
that we have 1000 records.
We have repeated the process, we
have kept on taking the samples
without replacement.
Sorry with replacement 1000
times.
So we got 1000 training data.
And then after getting the
training data, what we do is
that we are going to remove the
duplicates so that we are going
to get the training data with
the without duplicates and we
use that for for doing the uh,
what would be model building?
So now if you do this, how many
of the records?
So what is the value of this
approximately 1 -?
1 by 1000, to the power of 1000.
So what is the approximate value
of this?
Almost close to 1.
Almost close to 11 by E.
No, no, no, no, no one one
minus.
Or.
We have taken 1000 samples and
what we did is that each time we
had taken a sample with
replacement.
So it record not getting
selected is approximately the
probability is 1 by East so that
is what we are saying is that
that is approximately equal to
0.368.
So what we are saying is that if
we do this, we are going to get
the test training data size will
be 632.
And the test data will be 368.
Is this is this clear or is it
confusing?
Sir, can you explain what do you
mean by with replacement?
That's.
Can you explain what you mean by
with replacement victory
placement is that you have 1000
records.
You have taken training 1 sample
so you have not removed the
But they can.
sample.
You still keep the sample in the
data.
Removed the sample.
So now again, next time also you
go you have still have 1000
records and you are taking a new
sample.
Random sample.
And OK.
OK.
Thank you.
Is this clear bootstrapping you
end up with 6632 training and
Yeah.
Thank you too.
368 test and this may be the
reason why it motivates many
researchers to say, take 60%
sixty five 6% as uh training and
the 33% as test.
But then it's a OK you you get
it.
Anyway, this is a.
This is doing a random sampling
and then what is the problem
with the random sampling?
It can end up by us.
It can end up by.
That is right.
It it need not be stratified
because random sampling is is
something which is when we have
we do not have a when you do not
have a full idea about the data
then random sampling is good.
So that is to say, we are not
sure about the many class
distribution or so, but then the
point is that random sampling is
supposed to, for example, there
each attribute has got possible
values and then we do not know
the importance of this attribute
towards the.
So in that case, random sampling
is a good test case because it
is a, it is going unbiased, but
then The thing is that we may
have a knowledge about the data
that random sampling may not
capture.
So for example we let's say we
are talking about a population
which is where this is a I think
on the first day we had taken an
example where a political
election where we have to depend
on a sample to predict the
result.
So now the challenge is that
let's say the gender is a strong
influencer, so that is possible
that female voters have a strong
preference for certain party and
they male looters have a strong
preference for another political
party.
So now now the point is that
that information, if you have
that information then you will
make sure that both of them are
represented proportionally in
the sample.
But then, if that information is
not there, random sample is
fine.
But if this information is
there, then you would rather go
for a stratified sample.
Are we In Sync?
Is is that uh making sense?
So.
So in that sense, random
sampling is not bad but and also
random sampling can be unbiased.
But then but then there is,
there may be a useful knowledge.
Uh.
Such as which it can be used by
a stratified sampling and random
sampling may not capture that
knowledge.
OK, I'm hoping that.
Yeah. Yeah, I'm not.
I won't doubt.
Yes, Mr SAURABH. Yeah.
Uh, that .32?
That .32.
In the past.
Can you repeat the point?
Can you?
Can you repeat it?
Your voice is a little lower.
Yeah.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
There is something that.
Sorry, they commit to that 0.63.
0.63.
Yeah, 0.63 you want to know why
it is why it is 66, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, but
yeah.
Yeah, I can do that.
Yeah, right, right.
So suppose that the training
data is 1000 or it can be 10,000
or it can be anything.
Suppose that training data is
something like the D records.
Uh, OK, so now let me let me let
me do actually calculation then
maybe you will appreciate.
So suppose that I rise, I rise.
Uh.
1000 records is 0.999 raised to
the power of 1000.
He's equal to .367.
OK, so now I do another thing G
0.9999 raised to the power of
10,000.
He is also equal to
approximately same.
You can see that when you have
an equation of this form, it
tends to a limiting value, which
is the definition of E so when
limit D tends to Infinity, 1 -,
1 by D to the power of D is
approximately equal to 0.367,
which is defined as one by.
So uh.
Mr SAURABH, does that answer?
Yeah.
Yeah, so.
Yeah.
OK, so this is the.
This is the definition of E that
has been very valuable in
mathematics because you know
when differentiation that has a
very specific behavior of the
polynomial.
Uh, yes.
Uh, OK, Mr Rajesh.
Okie Okie umm.
Maybe we can.
But even then I can take it off.
I can take it off and then there
is a bit lower.
Yeah.
OK, I I think I think I think I
think it is clear possibly
intuitively it feels like much
smaller percentage of the
population.
So The thing is that yes, that
is what it looks like.
But then the because that is why
we choose sampling with
replacement.
When you do a sampling with
replacement, even when you try
many times, there is a
possibility that yeah, we even
with a, the point is that we are
also doing trying to create the
sample of the same size as the
training data.
So you know that when the
training data is very big, the
probability of not getting
selected is very high each time
and then when training data is
small then the probability of
not getting it so in either case
it turns out to be same.
OK, OK, so this is good.
So now let us go into another
aspect which is which is
actually interesting concept
that is coming from.
Ohh which is coming from radio
characteristics receiver
operating characteristic.
Suppose that we are sending a
music from one place to another
place through a radio
transmission.
So what we know is that we want
to do a high fidelity
transmission, so high fidelity
transmission typically means
that you need to capture every
frequency from you need to
capture every frequency from I
think 20 Hertz to 20 K Hertz.
And a typical hello, I think
it's sufficient if you capture
from 300 to about 4K, it's
sufficient for a normal voice
recognition, it is 3 as.
Now the point is that suppose
that you are transmitting the.
So now the question is, what is
the basis on which we do a
filtering.
So we need to filter because
when we do a radio transmission
happens.
What is the frequency at which
the noise operates?
Noise exists at all frequencies.
So what does that mean?
So you reduce the reduce the
signal bandwidth that you
accept.
Essentially you are reducing
also the noise that you accept.
Is there a concept clear so the
more you want to get in the
signal fidelity you are
capturing your forced to capture
more noise in the receiver.
Is that clear?
So the more fidelity you want,
you end up in a way capturing
the more noise from the
environment.
But if you are satisfied with
the lesser fidelity, you maybe
get end up with the lesser
noise.
So this is in fact a problem
with the classifier.
So we say that we want to have
an extremely high recall, but
the moment we say that we want
to get 100% recall, that is
possible only if you are
capturing the entire negatives
also into the positives.
So now, now let us see, maybe we
we will take the classifier
example as we go ahead.
So we want to we have two
elements, one is the true
positive rate and the other is
the false positive rate.
So what we are saying is that we
want to capture all the true
positives, so then that means
the reality is that if you want
to capture all the true
positives, you also end up
getting all the false positives.
So that is all the negatives.
Also into the false positive.
So the when you say 00, So what
we are saying is that we declare
everything to be negative class,
then the true positive rate is
zero, true negative rate, false
positive rate is also zero.
But then ideally we want true
positive rate to be one and
false positive rate to be 0.
So.
So what happens is that when you
try a classifier with the
different parameters add you try
to increase the true positive
rate.
The way it captures the false
positives is really representing
the Roc curve.
The curve that red curve that
you are seeing, which is called
Ormoc Curve and Blue Line which
is representing a diagonal line
is indicating a random guessing.
A random guessing is when you
have a two class problem.
Random guessing will give you
50% times, right?
Right.
Because we have two equal
classes and we are just trying
to do a random guess so.
So now what we are saying is
that the more the area under the
red line, we think that the
classifier is of superior type.
OK, so now now the point is that
Roc curve is possibly we can.
Uh understand with the help of a
visualization that is presented
by some expert.
So now let us say this is
representing the data that we
have.
There are two classes.
One is representing positive
class red curve and then
negative class which is blue
curve.
OK, so this is the distribution.
So now you we always know that
it is never possible to have a
complete differentiation.
So that happens in all types of
fields.
For example, you want to say
whether who will buy a
motorcycle or car.
You cannot put a income as let's
say, a differentiator.
So you will never get an income
accurate line saying that, OK,
anybody below 75,000 income will
buy a mop the cycle and anybody
with income greater than 75,000
would be a car that will never
happen.
There may be somebody with
60,000 income will buy a car
and there will be somebody with
an income of 1,00,000 who will
buy a motorcycle.
So the classification problem in
real world is never going to be
real.
World Data set is never going to
be a clean cut case where you
can build a simple classifier
and the whole world will follow
the rule.
Uh, so the point is there is
always going to be an overlap in
spite of that, we want to build
a classifier.
That is the best possible.
So now this is giving.
This is having a smaller
overlap, so that means the Roc
curve that we are plotting will
have a large area under it.
But now let us say we have got a
data where there is a
significant overlap.
Then, as we change the
threshold, you can see the RC
curve that has got a much lower
area than one, and as we move it
is changing.
We can keep changing the because
we are using single threshold so
each time we change the
threshold we get a different
classifier.
But then whether a threshold is
a good classifier or not that we
are checking.
So as we move the threshold, we
are the this classifier point is
moving from the false positive
versus the true positive point.
And now we can see that when the
data is this then it is simply
is becoming a random guess
because we have got complete
overlap of the positives and
negatives and so any point that
you take is virtually giving you
the trend.
Online, does that uh?
Does that clarify the concept of
area under the curve, then false
positive versus the true
positives and then the plotting
of the curve?
So this is again the same
picture drawn in on this slide
and this we can take a data set
which is essentially taken from
the textbook.
So we are saying that there are
10 instances and then we want to
build a classifier.
So there is only one way we can
build so that is we need to
create a threshold above which
we call that as a positive class
and below that we call it as a
negative class.
So we can start building the
various classifiers, and then we
plot.
So the AOC curve that we got is
the red one.
So the point is that AOC curves
help you to compare various
approaches to build classifiers.
So one model one is built using
one approach and Model 2 is
built using another approach.
So it tells you that, which is
the one which is performing the
better based on the area under
the curve.
So what do we find?
OK, so now what we do is, uh,
that is what we wanted to
discuss about model evaluation.
So now we're going to the new
topic, which is prediction.
So it's a small topic.
We are going to learn prediction
in detail again later using more
complex methods in future
courses, so we will just
introduce the prediction because
it is actually same
classification with a minor
change.
So we just understand what is
prediction.
So.
So the prediction is that when
we are predicting a numerical
value, classification is when we
are predicting a nominal value
or a categorical value.
So the prediction is trying to
build a continuous valued
function that is indicating what
is that.
So the there are many cases
where we want to get a
continuous value prediction.
So this can be either with
respect to the profit sales
house price, then temperature
distance.
Many, many of them are
continuous valued functions, so
we want to make the prediction
based on many uh attributes that
are determining its value.
So the technique that we use is
prediction.
The OK, the problem is called
prediction and the technique
that we use is a regression
techniques.
So these are all called
regression techniques.
A regression is typically what
we do is that we have the target
values which are known.
For example, we have been given
a data like this, so let us say
the area of a House and the
quality of the neighborhood.
Neighborhood can be excellent or
good or average.
So now let us say uh, so I Ravi
is 1000 square foot and
neighborhood is excellent.
Then the price, let me say in
millions, I'm putting this as a
7,000,000 so area is 1200 and
then it is neighborhood is good
and then this is 7.2 EDI is 1000
and this is a average
neighborhood.
Then you're getting it for 5.5
million then so when you get a
data like this, so we need to
think in terms of creating a
model that will get the value
for a new house that you are
seeing in a particular
neighborhood and you want to
predict what should be the price
that you should be paying for
it.
So based on this type of data,
we need to predict.
So the so here we can have many
attributes, some of them numeric
and some of them are nominal,
and typically to build this
model we require the all the
predictors or independent
attributes.
So we need to somehow convert
them into numbers.
And and our.
Otherwise, we need to have a
different methods of.
We'll we'll look at if we don't
want to convert them into
numbers, what we have to do is
we'll look at them in a short
way.
So the point is that we this
regression can go into multiple
ways, so one needs we can have a
linear.
Can be linear or nonlinear.
It can be regression.
Can also be simple.
So one independent variable.
Odd multiple.
So we mini independent
variables.
And it is also possible that
sometimes we end up with other
models where we see that some of
the variable we have to take a
log of that to get this and
regression 3 is that we cannot
find a linear easy linear
solution.
Then we start going in for a
purely nonlinear solution and
based on many attributes that we
start considering.
So let's see how does a
integration work with the?
Thank you, Sir.
Ohh and then you go on like
that.
Will you go once like I have?
Sorry, I was nothing.
Yeah, uh, yes, not in.
Today I'm gonna study.
Yes, Mr SAURABH, can you can you
repeat the question, go back to
Let me go to.
the previous slide.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, go back to the previous
slide, this slide, right.
This slide right?
Uh, no.
Uh, #6.
No.
Uh #6 with the one before this.
OK, this one.
Numbers that.
This one?
Yeah, OK. Yeah.
It's OK.
This book book event.
OK then.
Yeah.
OK, so now now what we are
saying is that regression can
take the find form of equation
which looks like this.
Suppose that we have got
predictor variables.
So many predictor variables?
Uh, let's say these are all the
predictors X1 to XN, and then we
want to build a model to for the
target.
Why?
Which is single variable then
what we can do is that we can
write this equation where W is
representing set of parameters.
So these parameters can be in
case of a linear regression.
So we are going to get.
So for example, there are yen
predictors, so we require N + 1
parameters, right?
Because it's a linear, so we can
only have a multiplier, the
coefficient, and then we meet,
we can have one offset.
So so that can be that is one
way of looking at it.
If we are doing a linear, but if
it is a nonlinear, we may have
many more parameters.
And and the way we can do it is
that we will, when we build the
model, the model is represented
by the function F So what we get
is that we will seldom get the
model that exactly matches with
the dataset.
So we will end up with some
errors.
So that is how the model is.
So we have been given the
training data where X is given
and Y is given.
Both are given, so we need to we
need to find the function F such
that when we do this equation,
when we get this equation we can
minimize.
E or in fact, we need to we
typically E square is minimized,
which is the uh, the square of
the errors.
So the the point is we when with
simple linear regression, so
using the least squared error
the best fitting straight line
can be obtained using this
equation.
V this is representing the
gradient.
And this is representing the
offset so that is to say then we
get this equation.
So this is representing the
offset.
When X is equal to 0 and then
this ratio is representing.
Right.
So this is equal to.
Let's say this is equal to M.
So what we get is Y is equal to
MX plus C so this is in this
case.
This is actually this is the
gradient is equal to 1 and
offset is equal to 0.
OK, so so now what we can do is
that we can we can do a I hope.
We'll do a very quick example
just to show that how this
works.
So this is we can say I hope
you're able to read this.
OK, so this we can call this as
X.
The area of the house and the
price of the House, we can call
this as a Y and then what we
need to do is that to get that
gradient we need to compute the
mean of X mean of Y and then
calculate this, multiply the
difference from the mean for X
and with the difference from the
mean of the Y for each
observation and then sum it up
and divide it by the square of
the independent variables.
Distance from the mean.
So so the so we can hopefully do
it very quickly.
So we can compute the mean.
So the mean for this one is
going to be 176.
And mean for this one is 78.
Right.
OK, so now what we need to do is
that we need to compute X minus.
Mean of X and we need to
compute.
Why minus mean of Y and this we
can call it as a?
Be and then so.
OK, So what is the value of
this?
This is minus 4, right?
This is minus 26.
This is fine.
This is minus 2.
This is 18.
This is 9 right?
Similarly, we have to compute
for the Y minus this.
So this is coming out as six,
this is minus 15.
This is minus one.
This is 0.
This is 12.
This is minus 2.
This we can call this as a queue
and then we need to compute uh P
* Q and we need to compute the P
multiplied by.
Beat so.
So this will come out to minus
24 then minus 390 -, 5, G, zero
then.
Oh sorry, this is 390 + 390 +
290.
Let's do 90.
Yeah, plus 390.
This is uh, uh one 216, right?
This is minus 18.
OK.
And then, uh, this is this is
16.
The seeds are 676254324, then
81.
So now what we need to do is
that we have to take a summation
of this.
This is coming out to 559.
And this is coming out to be
summation of.
This is coming out to 11/26.
So.
So now what?
What this means is that the what
is the gradient?
Gradient is equal to.
This will come out to be.
Paint will be 559 by 1126.
So this is equal to 0.49.
And offset.
Offset is equal to, so we have
to take the mean of Y which is a
so so OK I need to take equal
to.
78 -, 0.49 multiplied by.
How multiplied by 176, right?
Cool.
Well, we're fine, right?
So this is coming out to or.
This is not mean of why minus
49, so this is coming out to
minus 8.2.
So what is the equation equation
is 0 point?
G -, 8.2.
4 + 0.49 * X So that is what is
going to give us the OK.
This is I think I showed to
remove this.
So so this is the way you can
derive the the simple linear
regression.
So simple linear regression is
all it is doing is minimizing
Set.
errors.
Yeah.
Off-site means Esquire, right?
OHS.
It means he square, right?
Pardon.
Of sit here is is square.
Offset is square.
Again.
No, no.
Offset is the gradient, the
place where the line meets the
when X is 0.
OK.
Just let me let me go to that
slide where sorry, I had drawn
that this.
This is the offset, the place
where we are seeing you can you
can see this offset that line is
intersecting X is equal to 0 AH.
This is the point.
This is called as offset.
OK, OK.
OK.
Yeah.
And when kisses that
calculation.
The offset, offset offset is
this.
Then, out of these two data, how
did we decided which one is the
How long these two data?
How they decided which one is he
and ritually skim?
and which one the skew?
I mean we have we have a area
and.
The POK.
Yeah. Yeah.
No, no.
See.
See now.
Now the point is that that is
something we know that price
depends on area but not the vice
versa, right?
That is how we go with the house
price, right?
This is this is just we are
taking one simple example which
is common.
So independent variable is the
area of the house and dependent
variable is the price.
Is that the question or
something else?
Yeah, that's the question.
So the.
So OK.
Yeah, fine.
Right.
So any any case that has to be
given, what is X?
What is?
What is Y has to be given?
So if it is really a domain way
about which we have no
knowledge, then there can be a
confusion, right?
When this is all sit formula I
want to.
Ohh then this is pop set formula
you want to uh.
The formula how did we get the
formula and offset offset offset
Yeah. Hopefully.
Yeah, opposite offsetting the
conclusion.
formula?
Is this one?
Yeah, this one.
No, it what is the question
there in the opposite formula?
Uh, in the calculation there is.
Uh, in the calculation?
Umm, yeah, yeah, that is, that
is what we have used.
And the.
We have used to calculate the
offset because we know the mean
Yeah.
of X&Y also, and we know the
gradient first, we find the
gradient and then we find the
offset to minus 8.2 this one to
To minus 8.24 this wanted to see
how it came.
see how it is.
But can you repeat the question?
Ah, when this is minus 8.24, how
it how it is to that calculation
Uh, we give the microstate to
put money on things to that
I just want I missed.
conversation and missed.
Why minus Gideon into X?
Why minus katien into X?
OK, not X the mean of X mean of
X mean of yeah.
Sorry, X-Men takes me off.
So Y so that we can derive
actually that requires a little
bit of partial differential
equations, we can derive it, but
I won't do it now.
This is just you take this as a
formula as it is.
If you want, we can do it in
canvas or show how to derive
I I.
this equation using the partial
differential equations we I just
Winky said.
I just wanted to see 8.24 how
reach to that value.
want to speak 8.2443.
How did we get 8.24?
Yeah, yeah, yes, yes.
That is what you are saying,
yes, yes.
But how did we get 8.24?
OK.
Yes.
8.24, we got it through through
the same equation, right?
This is the equation you see the
equation.
Can you see that?
OK, all put things it 28.49 and
11760.49 is a pretty 176.
OK, I'll put the yeah, this is
the equation.
You can see.
Yeah, 149 in 11262.49 is a
pretty yeah.
0.49 is the gradient.
We got 78 and 176 are the mean
values we already know.
Ah, OK God.
Ah, OK, good.
Thank you. Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
So, Sir, whichever that goes to
the act, which is dependent
So, Sir, whichever.
Yes, Mr Rumic, which is Brendan.
variable that goes through my
right?
Very well.
That goes through by right
dependent variable is.
Why?
Right, right, that is correct.
So now we will look at few
concepts.
So that we can also have
multiple linear regression, so
multiple linear regression is
more difficult, but we can solve
it.
Still we can solve it when we
solve it.
We have this approach, just this
is only for.
If you want to explore on your
own, I don't want to go much
further into this is based on.
We are deriving this using the
partial differential equations
on the matrix expressions, so
when it is a multiple linear
regression, we know that the
parameters that we have to the
data set is going to become a
matrix and then the parameters
are becoming A1 dimensional so.
Uh.
And suppose D is the size of the
number of variables, so they're
metrics will be d + 1 * 1, so
that will be the parameters so
that we call that as a Theta and
then we want to solve the
analytically this.
And when we solve this, we are
going to get this closed form
solution.
So which is that we have the
observations X from the training
data X transpose multiplied by
X.
Then the universe metrics and
multiplied by the X transpose
and then why that is how you are
going to get the Theta and this
is just to indicate that even
for multiple uh multiple
regression like simple linear
regression we can do it using
the formula.
But then that is going to be
very costly operation if the
number of dimensions is logged
with small dimensions, we can
still do this and other approach
that is typically taken, which
you're going to study in depth
later, is the gradient descent
which is, which can be done as a
linear algorithm, which is that
you incrementally keep adjusting
the values of Theta by looking
at the direction of the
correction based on the gradient
with respect to the change in
Theta.
So how to reduce the error by
changing the Theta is something
that you can compute by as a
gradient and then with the help
of a learning rate you keep on
adjusting the value of Theta.
So this is a kind of a trial and
error, but this is what is
actually driving the entire
machine learning and the neural
networks, which is that you
learn the parameter through
gradient descent, but that is
left for another course and then
you will learn it in depth.
So.
So the point is we can solve the
linear regressions using the
various approaches we looked at.
The simplest approach?
The complex approaches we are
living it for you to explore or
learn it in the next semester
and then we can have another
problem which is a nonlinear
regression.
Nonlinear regression is a far
more challenging problem to
solve, and typically what we do
is that we convert it into a
linear regression problem.
And what we do is that when we
have a nonlinear regression with
one variable, we convert it into
a linear regression with three
variable.
Suppose so.
This is your polynomial of order
three, so we are converting it
to a linear regression with
three independent variables and
then solve it and for this we
have the methods like.
We can use the gradient descent
to solve, but then if you want
to stick with a nonlinear
regression, it is really becomes
very challenging because the
problem is that the nonlinear
regression you want to take
directly the nonlinear
regression.
This this is a typically non
intractable problem, so the the
approach that is taken always is
that convert it into a linear
regression through
transformation and solve it.
And this is this is 1 approach
and then there are there are
actually other approaches that
there are two other approaches
which we can we are briefly
going to look at one is called
as a regression tree.
Regression Tree believes in
taking the approach like this.
It takes.
It converts this graph into this
form and thereby it tries to
solve.
So this is the this is the
approach of regression tree we
are going.
We are seeing it in a short
while.
So you approximate the graph
into in two a kind of points
horizontal lines which will be
approximating the entire graph,
or we have another one which is
which I can plot using a
different color which is.
Which is called as a model tree
which is building multiple
models that will approximate a
curve.
So both of them are not giving
you a nonlinear solutions, but
pretty approximate nonlinear
solutions.
So the regression tree is that
each leaf of the tree will have
a continuous value prediction.
So this is to say 1 leaf will be
corresponding to.
For example, corresponds to
this.
This indicates the value that is
indicated by Y1 here, and this
is indicated by, let's say 8
three.
So each leaf is indicated by a
continuous value prediction, so
that is regression tree and
model tree is even more tricky
one.
So each leaf is represented by a
new model.
Each leaf will have a different
model.
And the regression trees and
model trees tend to be more
accurate than linear regression.
That is easy to imagine, and so
can be used, and now we are just
taking some examples just to
understand what is the
regression tree.
So this is indicating multiple
variables, so this is a golf
player.
How many golf players show up at
the golf course depending on the
weather?
So what we do is that we start
finding the variable which is.
So the range of the variable is
25 to 52, right?
Minimum is 2323 to 52.
It is a wide range, So what we
try to do is that we try to
reduce the range.
So now let us take we take
Outlook is sunny and let's say
temperature is cool.
Now let us say sunny and cool is
38, so we are able to put get
single value and when the
outlook is sunny and the
temperature is hot so one is 25
and 30.
We are taking the mean of 25 +
30 / 2, so we are taking the
average of 25 and 30 and we are
getting 27.5.
So now what we see is that at
every point, typically the
approach that is taken, the
algorithm that does is that, uh,
it tries to reduce the variance
of the data.
So you take the entire data
variance and then take subset of
the data and the subset like the
when we had the decision tree,
we were dividing it based on the
attribute and we are trying to
minimize the Gini value and in
this case we are trying to
minimize the variance of the
target variable.
So that is the intent.
And so that is conceptually, if
you understand, that's good
enough and then we can have a
model tree where we are building
multiple models to represent the
data and each model is a
distinct model.
OK, so this is all I wanted to
cover as the topic and we can.
Are there any questions?
Uh, on what we discussed till
now.
Are Mr Rajesh has asked a
question?
The topic currently being
covered in the method
multivariate calculus is applied
specifically for this.
But not a question, not a
question of just everything. So.
Not a positive.
Yeah.
OK.
OK, fine. Fine. Fine.
OK, so if fine if you are
learning it, that's good.
But let's say in any case you
will study in detail in machine
Can you once explain?
learning.
Thank you, Sir.
Can you punch, please?
Please explain foil, gay and
boom.
Yes, Sir.
Somebody's asking a question.
I'm getting a low voice.
Venkata now I'm audible.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Can you?
Can you speak louder?
Can you once explain for you
gain and coffee in brief?
Can you once explain for you
gain and coffee?
Uh.
Which one foil gain?
What did you say?
Yeah.
For your gain and point.
You know, or you gain any voice?
Yeah, for you gain.
Yes, yes, we can do that.
We can do the file gain and what
is the other thing that you said
I couldn't hear.
5 pruning.
Alright, 40 Paul.
Yes, yes, we'll do that.
We'll we'll look at the file
gain and file problem.
Yes.
In any other question, yes.
Anything else?
OK, So what do we do is that
we'll take a 3 minute break and
then we'll review the entire
what we discussed in the course
so far for the mid semester.
Course review.
We'll just spend half an hour
and at that time I will also
take little simple example of
while gain and file prone to
explain.
Is that fine.
OK.
Thank you.
Focus. Yeah.
OK, let's get restarted.
So what we do is that we do a
quick review of the entire.
Uh, see levels.
What we have done it till now,
so I'll take this is just to get
the questions from you.
So the first session was more
about data science and we
discussed what are all the tasks
that are there in the data
science and then what are the
processes that are used and so
on.
So this is the and then we
started looking at the various
types of attributes that are
present and from data science
perspective, we are going to
group the attributes using a
different criteria.
Then typically that is done when
you are doing storing it as a
file or a in a database, because
here we are not concerned about
really about the size, but then
we are looking at a different
characteristics so that we can
use it for analytics.
We looked at data quality, then
we have seen that data quality
is something not so easy to
define.
So there can be many aspects to
that.
So so including.
And we have seen that given data
there are going to be all kinds
of problems including the noise
outliers, then missing values.
And so we have to find ways to
fix the problems, and these
fixes can never be completely
satisfactory.
But we may have to use some
knowledge of the domain or we
have to go to the some domain
expert and understand what is
the what is the impactful way to
fix the data.
And we have also seen that one
of the problems with the data is
the dimensionality.
And so the when we are trying to
reduce the dimension, so the
model becomes more interpretable
and also the IT is possible to
look at the interaction between
the various dimensions better.
But if you have too many
dimensions, so we may never be
able to capture the interaction
among those dimensions.
We had looked at these
statistical descriptions so that
included ohh many of these and
we had also seen that given a
data so we may want to make some
assumptions about the
distribution.
So this is more of an assumption
so that it follows a normal
distribution because there are a
lot of mathematics have been
developed around the normal
distribution and then the tables
are all available.
But really, the data that we got
get is represented by.
So the point is, it is the way
we approximate and then go ahead
is the one.
So it is and added to that we
what we know is that we may
seldom get a distribution which
is symmetric.
So so that all that is the other
thing that we have to live with
and we can measure the
dispersion of the in the data
using various measures.
And we have looked at how to
create 5 number summary and then
create a box plot.
And we may need to do a
normalization when we have that
data because the data comes with
wide ranges.
Uh, there is no set range, so
the attributes impact and its
measurement are the scale may
not have any relations.
So in that sense, so if there is
a strongly impacting data, but
it's measurement is an only
millimeters.
So we need to think in terms of
doing a proper normalization so
that its value can be captured
properly and similarly the
income can go into billions and
trillions, but then the impact
it will do to the our problem.
Maybe may may not be in direct
proportion to that, so we need
to think in terms of a
normalization.
Again, there is nothing like a
perfect normalization, but then
we may have to try various
approaches.
So so that, uh, the the impact
that the normalized variable
creates will be reasonable.
And then when we have complex
data objects so the this is the
distance between.
And we can we can perform some
data.
What?
What we call is as redundancy
identification through the
techniques such as uh,
correlation, covariance.
And and then the chisquare.
And then we looked at
classification and prediction.
So classification, we have seen
that we can we looked at
Decision Tree and then rule
based.
And in the decision tree, we
looked at Ginny and then
entropy.
Or gain ratio.
And rule based we had looked at
the foil.
What else?
The prediction.
OK, So what we'll do is that
we'll go into the slide deck
that has got.
Ohh rule based this we discussed
in the last class right.
Sir, can we have your question
properly?
2nd we have your question
properly.
Love the last year.
Miss Ruby, I posted 1 sample
Question paper in canvas and let
me let me also forborne you that
these question papers come with
no warranty or guarantee kind of
things.
So the point is the maybe
because the last semester you
have to check because they're
different faculty has taken the
I was not involved with this
course, but I do not know
whether the that giving the
sample is good enough
indication.
I'm not sure whether the the
last year's pattern app I'll
have to find out where it is and
I'll have to give it.
I do not know whether I'll be.
I'll. I'll.
I'll give a try, but I I don't
know who has that last year's
question paper.
So would be a handy turn exam.
So we'll be handed down again.
Uh, I understand this
examination.
Yes, you may have to write it,
but then the question papers
will be given will be given to
electronically and then you can
possibly write it and then there
will be provision for scanning
it.
So if that is what you prefer,
and you will also have an
option.
So if you want to type the
answer in the then also the
machine will be available.
So what would be the poetter
like the heretic?
So what would the President like
that already the name it?
The you were saying whether the
questions will be required
calculations or not, right?
Yes, correct.
Yes, there will be some
questions requiring calculations
and few questions which may not
require calculation.
OK, so now let me go into the
like formulas provided the
Like formulas provided by in the
paper itself, like usually it's
formula will not be provided.
No, no.
provided.
Unfortunately, yeah.
The OK, so this is OK.
So you want me to tell you how
to solve this problem, right?
OK, I can do that.
I can do that.
OK, so did I.
OK, this is this was there in
the sample Question paper,
right?
Yes, Sir.
Yes, OK.
OK, fine.
Fine.
Then let me let me do that.
Ohh OK so so this is OK.
So what I will do is that this
this one you can try it and if
you have a problem, come back to
me I will solve what I'll do is
I'm going to do different
things.
Ohh what?
What happened?
So there is one question, Sir.
But there is one question for.
No, no, no data model for
Netflix.
Uh, no, not the model for the
Netflix.
Can you explain that?
Like how we can go.
Ah, let me.
Let me answer 1 by 1.
Maybe.
Maybe your question I will take
first.
So can you repeat the question?
I have not understood.
So.
So the paper which you shared in
that paper, there is one
So the paper with you here.
In that paper there is one
position related to model
question related to model
created model for Netflix based
creative model for Netflix.
Based on the user's OK.
on the use of image.
Yeah, OK.
How we go that question?
How we go that direction?
Like how we proceed with that
question?
Like how we proceed with that
question?
Like what?
We need to create and what
should be our thinking?
We need to create and.
What?
OK.
OK, OK.
So The thing is so.
So what you are saying is OK,
let me let me go into.
Yeah.
Or with them just close to.
This post to.
Yeah.
Just give me one minute.
Yeah, OK. Alright.
OK, so this is the.
On Netflix model in the sample
question paper.
OK.
OK, OK.
So so building your ML model
that recommends appropriate
If the.
shows for Netflix for kids.
Choose the specific performance
metrics that you would use to
measure effectiveness of your
model.
Justify your choice.
Uh, so.
So the point is that ohh the in
this case the you are really
thinking about what should be
the attributes right?
And then you you need to think
in terms of the attributes and
then you need to think in terms
of what is that you need to
predict.
So essentially this is to help
you create a problem.
For example, in your
organization you may have a
situation, but can you convert
it into a data science problem?
So that is what it is talking
about.
So in case of a Netflix, for
example movie, so the you need
to say what is appropriate for
the kids.
So what?
What is it that that you are
going to consider?
So it is possible that you are
going to consider the things
like the level of the violence
content, right and the weather.
You can convert that into the
the OR or you may need to think
in terms of the other
attributes, whether the theme is
related to the kids or is it
suitable for kids or not.
So the point is you need to
think in terms of the attributes
and then you need to think in
terms of what is the way in
which you are going to create
the model and then finally you
need to say whether the model
what is the result that you are
expecting from the model.
So this is more like can you
formulate a problem given some
context?
Does that uh, is that clear or
or are we?
Yes, Sir, one more thing.
Yes, Sir.
One thing.
Yes, yes.
Uh, so in this model we consider
user activity as well as the not
So in this model we consider
user acting as well.
the contracting.
No, no, no, no, no.
The user attribute only thing is
that the Netflix can ask is
whether you are a kid or not.
Then it can't ask anything else,
right?
It can't say that.
OK, OK.
What is your IQ level or what
type of person you are in that
type of things?
It can't ask.
It is really talking about age
appropriate, so see in any case
it's a.
It's really more of a soft
aspect.
So.
So the point is the evaluator
will be looking at the soft
aspects of the answer, so there
is no hard answer for this.
So this is a theoretical
question, right?
So this is a theoretical
question, right?
The but now we have to explain.
No, no, no.
My question is that again I'm
I'm little confused when people
start talking about theory.
What exactly is theory?
Maybe you can help me.
There is no calculation
question.
So do we need to?
No, no, I get it.
Ohh no no, I get this trying to
explaining the problem in terms
So while explaining the problem
in terms of data science, do I
of data science.
Do I need to say that this is
the data being used?
need to say that this is the
data being used?
To say you know these are the
attributes in here.
Since you know these are the
attribute, the class. Right.
This is the class.
Is that how we're supposed to
explain the problem?
Right.
That how we're supposed to make
that is right the see.
Yeah, because the model see the
question is when you're looking
at so specific performance
metrics, you would use to
measure the effectiveness of
your model.
And so the problem is that you
are trying to build a model and
then you were also looking at
the outcome of the model and
then the outcome of the model is
whether it's what is the age
appropriateness and then what is
it that you are expecting,
whether you are talking about
higher precision or higher?
Recall.
And what do you think about
that?
So possibly you need to talk
about those aspects.
Essentially, the soft
understanding of what we
discussed.
OK.
The should we also create a?
Should we also create a team?
Well, any ohh this isn't be of
order.
Pardon.
Ohh, this isn't the your model.
No, no, no.
The decision tree.
How will you create?
Because in this case attributes
and values are not there.
So you may say whether you want
to create a model, but I don't
think that that is expected in
this case.
At least it's not asking for
that, so it is asking only about
OK.
So in this case, recall is going
to help us raise.
this call is going to help us
raise that is possibly yes, yes,
right.
OK, then this is the.
This is the one you are asking
about and let me let me do it.
Do the problem on a slide.
So let me create a small new
slide.
And take this.
So I can do this now what we are
saying is that let us take did
it mention the type of the
heuristic has to be used?
The heuristic has to be it's
improved entropy.
It's entropy there.
OK, OK.
So we'll go with entropy.
Fine.
Yeah, alright.
OK, so now now the now the
question is that there are this
is in simple 2 attribute and
then one class label.
OK, so at the root.
So this is their data, 9 tuples
and out of them 4 positives.
9 tuples food positive and five
negative.
So entropy is of the data set is
4 by 9, log 24 by 9, less 5 by
9.
Log 25 by 9.
OK, so this is this is what is
happening.
OK, so I will hold this
computation.
I can do the computation, but
I'll just hold it and then
suppose that I use the attribute
one and attribute one.
I divide so it can take a value
of true or false.
So if we take say attribute
true, there are four tuples out
of them, three are positive and
one is negative.
Thank you.
False will be.
Obviously there are one positive
and for the negative, OK.
And then actually mute two, what
is it doing?
It is.
It is also having a values of
true or false.
So how many trues it has?
It has five trues and out of
them two or positive.
And three are negative, right?
And then falls.
So there will be 2 positive.
And then two negative.
So now what we have to see is
that which is the split which is
giving us a bigger gain in the
entropy.
So the problem is problem is
clear right?
So now I now I can do the
calculations.
No problems.
So first, uh.
The question was raised by May.
I know the menu who asked the
question so so is the problem
formulation clear.
So essentially solution
formulation yeah is not escape.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
Now it is clear.
So now I need to compute entropy
at every point every level, and
then I have to see which is the
better one.
So do you want to do it or you
want me to do it?
I can do that.
We have 20 minutes.
I can if there is some other
question, I'll take it.
Otherwise, I'll let me do this.
Because uh, so this is the the
root level 4 by 9 is .44.
I'm approximating that and then
what I'm doing is 4/4 log
divided by two log equal to
minus, 1.18 OK and so this is
let me put this.
This is minus 1.18.
And let me do this for let me do
this for the other one.
And I can.
OK, I can.
I will also multiply this with
the four by 9.44 right and that
will help.
Since we we will have a is is a
more steady calculator allowed
So this is the calculator allows
and calculate.
scientific calculator in the
exam?
Yes, yes, I think the calculator
is allowed.
Just check the check that
because you have to use the
calculator, otherwise the
machine will be there so the
machine may also have a
calculator within that.
Uh, but, but you you can
calculate if you take a
OK, OK.
scientific calculator with you,
OK?
OK.
OK, so this is minus .52 and and
I'm doing it.
I I'm remembering .52 and then
I'm doing it for .55 the next
1.55 is log divided by two log
equal to this and I multiply it
with .55.
So so now this is one is .52 and
other is .47 right?
So this is equal to .99.
Now let me do it for this this I
know +2 and minus one the +2 and
minus two.
So the entropy is 1, right?
So let me do it for the others.
So one is this is .4 and .6, so
I have to do it with .4 and .6.
So let me do that.
I'm doing it for attribute 2.
.4 log divided by two log equal
to then then multiplied by .4.
This is equal to 0.53.
OK, so this is .53.
I can keep it in memory.
Then the other one is a .6.
I think it is points point 68.6
log divided by two log
multiplied by .6 equal to.
.44.
OK, .44 and .53.
So .44 and .53 so.
For food and .53 is going to be
.97, right?
So this is .97.
This is 1.
So so now, now let us do for
this one.
OK, so this is one is 4 and the
other is 5, right, four
attributes 5K.
So .25 and .75.
Oh, OK.
This is minus 2.
Understood.
OK.
And then when you have.
.25 it is.
And then let us do it for .75.
Then multiply it with .75.
This is .31.
OK, so so now what we have is
that this is so this is equal to
point.
This is 1 by 4, so this is 1 by
4.
So this is equal to.
Ohh this is one by four of two,
so one by four of two is uh .5.
And the other one is .31.
I think I got .75.
What did I get .31 OK.
So this is .31.
And I have to do this with the
.2 and 2.8.
Same thing.
I'm doing with .2 log divided by
two log.
So I keep this in memory.
Then .8 log so you have to keep
doing the same thing.
OK, one is .26 and other one is
oh point 46.26 and .46.
So that will give .72, right?
So after this split, So what you
have is a .81.
This is 4 by 9 of .81 + 5 by 9
of .72.
So this is equal to
approximately, this is UH-70 so
nine.
So this will be .77.
So this will be quite no point
76.76.
So now this is.
Let us look at this.
This is 5 * 9 of 97 less 4 by.
Nine of one.
So this is equal to 0.99.
So now you can see that this is
actually 0.98 about .3985
approximately .985.
So here you can see that the
entropy gain on attribute 2 is
0.005 and the gain on this one
is .23.
Does that uh, does that clarify
whole thing or or have it
confused you more?
So attribute one is giving you a
better gain with entropy.
No, Sir. Understood.
Understood, Sir.
OK, OK, alright.
OK, so now we will go with any
other question.
Somebody you wanted for you gain
example, right.
So let me go into the foil gain
example.
So far are you gonna example?
I will.
I'll take the numbers.
So you so the calculations.
So suppose that we have 200
training tuples out of them.
100 are positive.
Or maybe I should make?
I think you you want so 200 or
negative and 100 or positive 300
training tuples and then the
Rule 1.
Let's say is selecting uh based
on the predicates it is
selecting 50 tuples and out of
them 30 are positive and 20 are
negative.
So what is the foil gain that we
are getting?
So the foil gain for Rule 1.
Is equal to 50.
Sorry 30, because the rule is
for positive tuples, so
essentially the rule is for
positive tuples, so we are
taking the positives, so 30
multiplied by log 230 by 50.
Minus log 200 by 300.
Or does that help?
Or do you need some mood
clarification on foil gain
calculation?
I do not know who has asked.
I forgot the name.
Yeah, it helps.
Is it clear or something more
needs to be somebody posted a
Yeah, it's been.
chat message.
Can you go back to slides?
Then you go back to slides.
Yeah, I go back to the slide.
OK.
OK, Mr B's.
Yes, go ahead.
Sutter, how you took the second
part.
Center how you took the second
part.
For rule one, you have taken,
uh, divided from the film.
The project one you have taken,
uh 100 by 300 from the 200 you
are asking about 100 by 300.
Is it right?
Right, right.
Right. Right.
Ohh 100 by 300 is because the
test training data has got 300
tuples and then 100 or positive
and 200 are negative.
OK.
OK. OK.
Yeah.
I'm Mr Durai Rajan.
You are saying that give me a
sample question paper that looks
more like a question paper that
is going to come.
We have not yet set the question
paper and that is that we will
not accept as a request because
that will defeat the purpose of
learning, so we would rather
want you to learn the whole
But no.
No, like instead of.
thing and get 10 marks rather
than learn only the question
paper and get 30 marks.
That is not something that bits
will encourage.
Are you?
Last night.
You got me wrong, Sir.
Hey, you got me wrong.
Set actually.
Actually The thing is you said
like the previous year Question
Actually The thing is you said
like the previous year Question
paper might not be of any use,
right?
paper might not be of any use,
right?
No.
In fact, even the model Question
Paper that I posted sample
Question Paper may not be of any
use, because that is what I said
OK then.
come with no warranty or
guarantee.
So you please learn on your own.
OK, fine.
Thank you.
OK.
Yeah.
And and I there was one more
question on calculator.
Yeah.
And and I there was one more
question on calculator.
Which type of calculator we can
use?
Which type of calculator we can
use?
I think scientific calculator
you can take and that is what,
because at least in the past, no
student ever has complained
about the restrictions on
calculator.
So I think there are no
restrictions.
So is there anything if I do not
think that the calculator is
allowed so they will not check
what type of calculator it is?
Is that the question or
something?
He's like the question or
something.
Hi Sir.
Hi sis.
So can you please here?
The server will we have class?
That will be just, no, no, there
is no restriction on the model.
Definitely no, no, there is no
restriction on the model.
I I do not know, I think, and
actually I I I will give you.
I I do not know.
Thank you.
And actually I I I'll give you,
I'll give you saying that paint.
I will give you a little hint.
Hint.
Can you mute yourself, please?
Can you?
Just one minute.
I'm muting everybody for just
for one minute.
Going to unmute everybody.
OK, because it is, it is echoing
my voice.
So see the point is you please
read the examination instructors
very carefully.
No, no, there can be no class
next week, Mr Mittal, because
next week you're going to have
one of the exams right?
So.
So the point is when you you
please study the whatever
document that they give you the
examination regulations
carefully why I'm saying this is
that because I will not be
present in examination center.
In fact, it's going to happen in
multiple examination center and
really the Proctor is going to
be and then the whoever is the
in charge is going to be really
taking a call and they will be
going with the document that has
been given to them.
So my interpretation may have a
lesser weight compared to
because the calculators I know
that there was no restriction on
calculator but in the but in the
statement I do not think that
they have put any restriction
in.
So please stay it I have not
seen any problem with that, but
otherwise the whatever things
have been mentioned in the rule
book, so it is the
interpretation of the Proctor
that finally determines whether
accepted or not accepted.
I'm unmuting everybody.
Yeah.
I I I just would like to ask
you, can you please provide us a
Prison.
I just would like to ask you,
your provider and prepare.
previous error question to?
I am unable to understand.
I am unable to understand it.
So can you please provide us
with previous year question
Maybe English provider you're
pushing pushing?
papers?
The old question papers.
Old question paper.
Board question paper.
OK, let me you like the right
fine.
Learn very fine.
I need to check with the faculty
who has taken taken and once.
I need to check with the fact I
need.
Let's take yeah, just two years.
We can practice them actually
and then.
But I don't encourage because
the simple reason is that they
What are you doing?
may not have covered it exactly
the way we do, because we set
the question paper.
Presently, the whoever faculty,
are they, they do it based on
their comfort.
So because asking for more
question papers is not really
encouraged.
OK.
Exact when you location is not
available OK.
Avengers are just window.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Just doing now.
Go ahead.
That help.
Uh detector in topical kissing
your date with?
Listen, you did.
Can you repeat again?
Uh.
Other entropical for the store
you did I somehow it was very
Other in tropical?
Yeah, entropy calculation. Yes.
Yes.
Umm I somehow it was good, but
there was, you know, and back
work.
Here was, you know, and back and
forth so to understand.
and forth.
Understand.
OK.
OK, I'll write the formula so
see the point is I will.
Yeah.
I will write the formula that I
have used.
So what I'm going to do is that
suppose I take the same thing,
Yeah.
I'm going to put it in another
slide.
So I'm going to.
OK so here I'm going to paste
it.
OK, so now now the problem is
that first OK so let me so here.
It is become very.
The point is that the training
data has got 9 tuples.
9 tuples out of them, 4 positive
and five negatives.
So entropy at the top is with
the training data is 4 by 9
minus of 4 by 9, log 24 by 9 + 5
by 9, log 25 by 9.
OK, so now let us split.
So let us split A1 into true and
false right.
A1 is true and false, so when it
is 3 and three plus and 1 minus
right.
So the entropy with yeah V1 is
equal to true is equal to is
equal to the.
Minus 3 by 4, log 23 by 4 + 1 by
4, log 21 by 4.
OK, similarly entropy of.
This is going to be 1 positive
and four negative right for
negative.
This is equal to minus of uh.
This is uh, 1 by 5.
Log 21 by 5 plus.
Ohh 4 by 5 and then once you get
this So what you need to do is
that entropy of end similarly.
So you got for entropy of on
using.
Uh, so you got the entropy for
this site and entropy for this
site.
So entropy of EA1 split is equal
to.
So this let us call it as E one.
Let us call this as E2, so
entropy with a one each.
So at the top we have 4 tuples
and in this case 5 tuples, so 4
by 9 of key 1 + 5 by 9 of E2.
So does that explain?
Yeah.
Yeah, yes.
Yeah.
Yes, that explains clearly
right.
So this we have done for even
really we have to do for like
We have that for even same thing
we have to do for a two also.
Yeah, right.
Parking lot.
God thank.
Thank you.
Thank.
And kisses.
Thank you. Yeah.
So the first we do the camera or
each attribute or that will
OK, I think that yes, Mr Kumar.
But for enter tribute or that
yes, we have to do it for all
work.
the attributes.
So for the attribute one only in
this slide it is done.
So you have to do the same.
No, no.
I mean, OK and the you entropy 4
by 5 nine.
Yes, yes, you entropy I4 by 8
next 4 by 9 + 5 five.
4 by 9 + 5 I.
Ah, yes, you've we need to
calculate the uh so can you.
Can you tell me what is the?
Because when we do the entropy
on A1, So what is happening is
that let me put it this way.
When you look at a decision
tree, uh.
Egg the root node at the root
node we have 9 tuples and when
we split using A1 so we ended up
with four tuples on one side and
five tuples on another side.
So there is a even associated
with one and then E2 and then
the overall entropy.
We have to do it as a weighted
sum of these two.
Is that the question or
something else?
Yes, Sir. Same.
Yes, I've seen so that is why
you need to do this when EE for
a one you need to do it this way
and similarly you for you have
to do it for E to E for A2,
whatever is the division that is
happening and for each division
uh attribute 2 may be dividing
it in using whatever number of
times.
In this case, I think it is
again 54 only, but then it can
be 637 to also.
Then for each a packet, you need
to compute entropy and then you
sum up the entropy for all the
paths using a weighted
summation.
That all said, could you please
tell we we have cheese square?
But it also could you please
tell?
Maybe it is square test milk
method?
Yes, the third we apply any
example for them.
We apply.
They can you use Skype, Square
test, Chi square test.
Guys, various guys well.
You use Chi square test.
You use when you have relation
between 2 nominal attributes, so
you need to think about nominal
attributes.
So the two nominal attributes
for which you know that whether
they are correlated or not and
how strongly related essentially
that is what it is going to
tell.
Does that clarify or yes, yes,
OK.
Yes, yes, yes.
So anything else that any other
question that I can answer?
OK.
If there are no questions, we
can close the session so.
Uh said if we have said, if we
have any question by next week.
Uh, so say if we have, if we
have any question, yes, fine
So please upload this slide
today.
Thank you.
next week.
Uh.
Ohh, because next week we have
exams.
Only because next week we have
exact.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So.
So if if you have questions, I
will be looking at canvas more
and answering it.
If something that is clear,
there is somebody who's asking
about the center and all that
that I could not answer, there
is nothing.
But if this is technical
question, I'll try to answer
ASAP and otherwise you can send
me an email also, but try to do
it before next 2-3 days.
If you keep it to the last day,
then I may not be able to catch
with you.
OK, Sir.
OK.
Thank you.
Yeah.
OK, so you can say you have the
my mail ID also on the canvas
site.
So if you want something you or
you can post it in canvas and
send me a reminder saying that I
have posted a question in canvas
and waiting for the answer
something, but try to do it next
Wednesday, Thursday.
Don't keep it for Saturday or
Friday.
OK.
And what more, OK, so.
OK so.
I'd be assignment will announce
after mid semester yes, and the
But he assignment grounded on
softer makes a mistake.
syllabus is a miss.
It is this singular segmenter.
And the syllabus user mispriced
with the syllable syllable thing
Rajesh Gupta syllabus is
everything that is covered till
During the summer.
that is covered till today.
today.
Thank you so.
And get the.